We have a voicemail number which is 2 1 9
2.
David P..
Here's a question that many in the audience
have been asking, while others in the audience
reject the framing.
Let's take a listen to the question.
Hey, David.
Yvonne from Corona, California.
Just wondering one paragraph, look, losing
so much since I'm getting sick of it.
I mean, this whole healthy AOC business and,
you know, people getting mad about her actually
trying to be a politician.
And, you know, people saying they awful for
Biden.
Yeah.
I'm sick of it.
And uncertainty progressives just like losing
anyways.
So, yeah, I mean, this is a fair question.
Not everybody agrees with the framing that
it's not cleared.
Not not all progressives like losing.
I think there's a couple of things going on.
There are progressives who have taken the
position that short term losses serve some
bigger purpose.
That will be a future win of some kind.
That's a position that is not an irrational
position.
I just don't think it's practical and I don't
think it actually works.
But you can rationally come to the conclusion
that you're willing to tolerate short term
and even medium term losses for some sort
of longer term win.
There are also people who genuinely don't
see what you and I might see as a loss.
As a loss, right.
Like there's disagreement there.
The AOC thing is a perfect example.
ICAO sees move to pragmatism as a positive
thing.
That suggests she has better political instincts
than I may be previously thought.
I got crushed for that position yesterday
on the program and a ton of people wrote to
me saying this is simply not a win.
In other words, it's not incrementalism versus
revolution.
It's simply disagreeing that this is going
to lead to any kind of win.
So I don't believe progressives love losing.
However, there is a fraction of progressives
who prefer to be in the underdog victim martyr,
always trying to claw from behind position.
And that is very motivating to a lot of people.
It's a good business strategy.
I know that there's a lot of, you know, sort
of activism outfits that essentially are constantly
fundraising on the basis of this come from
behind martyr victim position.
So I think that there's a little bit of everything.
There's there's a sort of all of the above.
I don't believe most progressives like losing.
They just have a disagreement about what we
what it means to win or lose at a fundamental
level.
Remember that we will be doing a big membership
bomb on April 9th.
Huge membership discount code will be going
out by email, be notified by getting on our
mailing list at David Pakman dot com.
On the bonus show today, producer Pat's triumphant
return.
We will hear about the ceiling caving in.
We will hear about it raining inside Pat's
apartment.
Pat will be back today and we will have much
more to discuss.
Get instant access to the bonus show by becoming
a member at Join Packman dot com or a patron
at Patriot CNN.com.
Slash David Pakman.
The David Pakman Show David Pakman dot com.